Ivanka Trump maybe one of her father's
most valuable assets the poisoned
polished counterweight to Donald's brash
and combative personality the 35 year
old daughter of the president will have
a significant voice throughout Trump's
presidency
here's Ivanka's path from teen model to
businesswoman to first daughter Ivanka's
Donald's second child born in New York
City in 1981 should a brief stint in
modeling in the late 90s before she
enrolled in college at Georgetown two
years later she transferred to her
father's alma mater the Wharton School
at the University of Pennsylvania in
2005 she went on to work as a real
estate executive for a family firm the
Trump Organization she then found
reality TV Fame alongside her father and
brothers as a judge on the Celebrity
Apprentice and around the same time
launched her own fashion brand she's
putting her name on clothing and jewelry
and shoes that other companies are
designing so that they sort of fit her
image that's Lindsay rub I'm a retail
reporter at Bloomberg News Ivanka and
her team capitalized on her name and
image to build a brand designed around
empowering women through her products
and this eventually developed into
Ivanka Trump's sort of pet initiative
called women who work where she
highlights you know stories of women who
are professionals and sort of have it
all like Ivanka Trump so it started as a
hashtag and it's going to be a book
that's scheduled to come out in May and
then this happened I am officially
running for president of the United
States once he secured that nomination
Ivanka became a huge part of her
father's campaign I could not be more
proud tonight to present to you Donna
[Music]
for the daughter of a man who promises
to bring all of the outsourced jobs back
to the US I'm going to bring the jobs
back from China and I'll take them back
from China from Japan we're going to
stop businesses from leaving our country
her clothing line is manufactured in
China and Vietnam I did approach the
Ivanka Trump organization and the
response that they gave was basically
that they're working with them to bring
the jobs back but that's that's almost
an impossible task but back to this
moment my father values talent he is
colorblind and gender neutral Ivanka the
self-proclaimed spokesperson and
defender of women's equal rights became
her father's most powerful supporter on
the campaign trail Ivanka Trump is
really credited with softening her
father's image particularly in the eyes
of a lot of women she was seen as
someone who could sort of pull him to
the left a little bit I like most of
trumps team Ivanka has no policy
background but she became the point
person during his campaign to talk about
women's issues he would bring her in and
really credit her with helping him
broaden his thinking on paid maternity
leave
child care equal pay which takes us to
Ivanka after her father won the election
people think that you're going to be
part of the administration Ivanka I'm
going to be a daughter but I've I've
said throughout the campaign that I'm
very passionate about certain issues and
as Inauguration neared Ivanka stayed
close to her father she moved into a 5.5
million dollar home with her husband and
three kids
her husband Jared Kushner once a real
estate's I owned in New York will now be
Donald Trump's senior advisor and Ivanka
with no role in her father's cabinet
stepped down from her position in the
Trump Organization as well as her
personal brand with focus on her
family's new move this is really
uncharted territory while her husband
will have a role in the White House
Ivanka Trump has said that she's not
seeking an explicit role her influence
might be more background it might be
more subtle no one really knows
and as trump's presidency forays into
his first 100
the policies she inspired her father to
propose for women in the workplace are
nowhere to be found on the White House
website and for now Ivanka's rule still
remains unclear but though she may not
formally be in politics she still has a
direct line to the president and the
White House
you